[Music]
the horsepower of the new models that
the Geneva Motor Show is packed into
aggressively styled exteriors
[Music]
Paulito Minelli is a design professor in
Cologne he studies the design language
of cars he's here to get a first
impression of the new models
if they're veining and our salmon
business of the cars I've seen confirmed
that there's a trend towards an
aggressive front end design studies have
shown that cars that have a dominant
look are popular with consumers look
which means they sell better based like
a violent affair now this of a car fare
to Minelli has scientifically analyzed
the design factors that make a car look
aggressive for example big models can be
intimidating
narrow windows placed up high on the
body recall the gun slits of a tank
v-shape designs at the front end
resemble arrow heads narrow headlights
bring to mind the squinted eyes of a
menacing glare
a lot of BMW designs are quite
aggressive
the L Bergen as they call it the elbow
effect of the lines and structures flare
away from the body of the car things
like the fenders and spoilers these
designs create an overall impression of
power master Baggins or was a tiny
museum eeeh a job cast we send as we
enter port lured there I'm starting will
see it as an athlete just getting ready
to start off he's looking ahead focusing
on what's about to happen
a BMW should always look like it's ready
to tear up the road ahead for the
Mercedes GTR seems ready to do the same
it's air intakes dominate its front
PMON coming because they don't like the
gills of shark
most of those slots absolutely no
question whatsoever but they give the
car a savage animal like parrots like
some raging wild here Javier I admin
this beast Yaga no Vanessa exactly we
call that the beast of prey look the GTS
our sportiest model and with the GTR
it's like having a racing car on city
streets I think an aggressive design is
perfectly appropriate the same features
are showing up in some of the new Audi
models
take a look at the grill on the q8 on
Allen [ __ ] oven of all the factors
that denote aggressiveness in car design
the most important has to be a front end
that looks like a big mouth and if it's
really open wide and looks dangerous and
dominating that will make the car look a
lot the nastier what are the steer the
[ __ ] deville car buyers don't want to
travel in a rolling symbol of moderation
they want to make statements they want
to buy products they can identify with
even if it's Ian no one knows that
better than Italian design legend George
o giugiaro he drew attention in Geneva
with a beast of a vehicle together with
his son for Brit serum he developed an
electric sports car that packs 1000
horsepower
[Music]
people select I think their car for
their way of driving so I can imagine
who choose this car how crazy is then I
not receive it when a car designed for
aggression drives by pedestrians cross
the street whose Genghis Nellis car sir
it's one way to make is a compact cars
to gain their customers a little more
respect on the road
[Music]
if they decide this relates to premiere
it's interesting to note that small or
popular cars are designed to look more
aggressive while dominant cars like
Rolls Royces and Ferraris look a little
more quiet and composed here the center
irui good cigar colossal avail the top
fight in the automotive world brands
that have always been trendsetters in
the industry haven't really stood out in
Geneva even if there's a sleek new
rolls-royce that lists for around half a
million euros
[Music]
you've got money you don't need to flash
muscle maybe that's what the brand is
trying to say maybe luxury brands like
rolls-royce will influence other car
makers and help make our streets look
just a little friendlier in the future
[Music]